my first guest you've seen her on two
dope queens she has a podcast called
couples therapy
please welcome the very funny naomi eck
paragon naomi thank you for being here
thanks for having me moses you're
looking well i've tried for this
prepping for this you look great thank
you for dressing up
well honey i need a reason i need a
reason they're just clothes
sitting in the drawer they're sitting in
the drawers they haven't been touched
have you bought any anything like any
new clothing item
yet i will tell you something i bought
three pairs of shoes all heels
because they were on sale and i know i
have nowhere to go
but i said you cannot pass by a deal
you can't yeah i've bought i've done
two two pairs of shoes tennis shoes have
not been out yet and now i don't want to
take them out too much time has passed
or i'm like i can't they've been with me
for this whole process
uh yeah this is this is really weird and
i please tell me if i'm wrong about this
but i feel like
for a lot of comedians they really need
an audience but for someone like you at
least the way you perform
i was just re-watching your two dope
queen set and then
some of your rants you do online it
almost feels like you don't need
an audience to do your thing
you just barrel through like this is my
idea you're either here or not
is that something that uh that you feel
or do you still feel like thinking like
i need it every 15 seconds i i miss an
audience
i miss it so much i do feel like i need
it to feel as though
my rant has done anything for anyone but
myself yeah
do you know what i mean like sometimes
it's like right who is that for
you self-indulgent fool but if you have
laughter it's like wow i've helped
people i've connected
right i think that's always kind of
helped me i think that you know this
idea that
because i think part of why i started
out being a little conversational and
not
too structured i think initially started
out out of
being afraid i wouldn't get the laugh
you know like you know how sometimes in
the comics you know they have that
cadence because they know that laugh is
supposed to come here
yeah and i could never be sure so i
sort of never really gave myself those
pauses
or that sense of this is the one spot
you're all supposed to crack up at
oh i know exactly what you're saying
because when you because
as a comedian you're watching that pause
and you you feel when it doesn't go well
and someone's like and that was the
whole
watermelon so anyway
but you guys that like that just oh the
whole
watermelon you know you say it again
hoping you can kind of set it up
and the extent to which you know
sometimes you might want that laugh to
propel you forward
and if you're not like i'm gonna propel
myself is there any colloquialisms that
you have
a pet peeve with like mine just for
example is just like
uh what else what do you guys want to
talk about
what do you mean what do you want to
talk about what do you want to talk
about you're the one
with the lights on you you know what
i've never
liked even though like i wouldn't think
about it only because you've asked i
realize
yeah i never like for some reason i'll
leave you with this
there's something like about like i'll
leave you with this he's like when you
get the light and you know you're about
to wrap up
it's there's i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is about the phrase
i'll leave you with this that feels a
little too
thank you sir well all right master
yeah i think it's a way of it's a way of
letting the hosts know that i know the
light has happened
and this is going to be longer than 30
seconds right
right is what that means i am going to
run the light so i'll leave you with
this
so growing up it wasn't always easy to
start my full one-man show there
so you've had the podcast to really keep
you busy but
the complicated thing is you do it with
your husband
well so it is like a work relationship
has that been beneficial for you guys or
have you noticed that like
just couple fights kind of bleed into
what would essentially be a work fight
well here's the thing i think we're if
you are living with your partner in the
pandemi
you are probably struggling with
distance
wanting some of it okay getting a break
okay moses i've always
said before pandemic i said the key to a
relationship you gotta miss a [ __ ]
okay you gotta have some time where you
ain't seeing that person's face moses if
you want love to work
yeah and so here we are in the pandemi
it's an apartment honey it's an
apartment he you know
i will sneeze in the living room he'll
say bless you from the office
and i don't like it i don't like it that
is no privacy
no i don't i'm also acquainting with my
partner and it's a
one bedroom i mean it's shutters it
covers the bedroom
there's just nothing you know i hear
like
mouth sounds in the next room i hear
someone's mouth working
i know it's too much and so then when
like so then we go to do the pod
and i find that the hardest thing is
just having something to talk about
you know like i know some people have
started podcasts in the pandemic and i'm
like
there's literally less to say than ever
yeah you know like i'm like what what's
the new episode what we do we walk to
the couch
i don't have anything to bring to this
podcast moses
yeah well it does feel like even the
small
shows i've been doing in backyards it
does feel like everyone's talking about
the same thing
because everyone is home everyone has
the same
stir crazy and then the same news cycle
so
it's really hard to be like i
accidentally bumped into this person on
the bus
there's no personal takes anymore
right i find i've been going to the past
if that makes sense like just like
thinking about stuff
where i'm like oh yeah that childhood
memory might make for a funny story
or that phone call with my aunt could be
something you know i mean stuff that i
would have never
brought up before but i'm like honey i'm
digging i'm digging
kick up family drama for material you
know just like hey remember that
that aunt that faked a heart attack
that really really get into it just to
generate material because it is a point
where
yes it is hard to have a new experience
that is
original and then two the turnaround of
material
have you done any any outside lives no i
haven't been out
i haven't been out how's it been it's
been
uh awful everything that would have been
a hell gig last year that you'd be like
absolutely not
um i'd rather eat a gun is now like hey
thank you so much for having me on that
show
we'd love to come back in two weeks so
every like outdoor
performing for cars performing for clap
machines
the worst case scenario is just a small
taste of what it used to be
so then that makes it the best show
right um and the material
more to your question is like the
material needs to turn over even faster
now
right because so much is happening if
you do something about game stop people
like
wow she's dusty
and that was like two hours ago that
happened right right did you buy any
stock
uh no i don't know anything about it
and i also am aware that it's not
interesting to say i don't know anything
about this
that's like the guys are like sports
sports sports like yeah i just
i respect it i don't get it i tried to
learn about it early in choir because
especially because i was like you know
what
if we all about to die i need some
bunker money and i felt like these old
white men they got bunker money and i
said i'm alert
i'ma learn and then your girl bought
some moderna stock and sold it
immediately
before it became ex before it became
money so i don't know what i'm doing
moses
what i'm telling you is i don't know
what i'm doing after a vaccine
no before i bought it when it was low
maybe when it was low
and no no profit cause i didn't
understand that you're supposed to hold
on to these things for a long time
i didn't know until you said that you
didn't know that you should
hold on to it and i was like well it's
not moving no one seems to be
it's not moving so i guess i'll just
give this back and i thought you almost
just like traded it
do you know what i mean like i pretty
much just like was like okay i gave you
this
now give me that money back and it's
like that's not what just happened girl
you just sold stocks i just thought i
was getting my money back
at the height at the height of their
success yeah i thought i was getting a
refund
i've enough to like worry about with
social media and try to post to like
then worry about
my robinhood app i feel like you've kept
on track though because these things
you could easily find distractions that
would take you away from the larger goal
i think you want to be a performer you
want to be a writer a performer
and i think the podcast is allowing you
to do that you're still getting
your voice out there your girl's doing
instagram videos i just need to know
that someone's seeing me
yeah accurate incredibly accurate your
trader joe's
went pretty well online i connected with
that
did you connect with that content do you
go to tj's yes yeah well we go
very rarely we have an uncompromised
person with us
oh it is i go in a full gray hazmat suit
a gas mask so i get people like taking
photos of me
liberal cook
but exactly you said you have people
should look it up i mean you have a
whole game plan
to go in there yeah i think it got me as
you you were talking about how people
were smelling
fruit yeah yeah like they're taking off
their masks to go
is this good is this i mean lemon
like moses it's a pandemi in and out you
ain't in a garden you ain't in a garden
they up in here trying to get the ripest
it's like honey this is survival also
it's trader joe's
you're no culinary expert okay we're all
the tj's because the price is right
so if you could just back up on that
whole thing
because i will tell you the last time i
went because i go to trader joe's now
every six to eight weeks
you know uh me and my betrothed we each
take a cart honey
so you got two carts piled high by the
end
but i went in i have asthma
and um i was allowed to go during senior
hours honey so i was there
it opened at eight i was there at 8 15.
that was beautiful that was beautiful
i'm telling you it was just us
and like 11 old people but this is what
i'll tell you
again at 8 15 am already out of corn
flakes
come on come on come on party out
who's buying the corn flakes the seniors
it's the one food
they can enjoy are you getting looks
from the other seniors because you look
young and healthy
well as soon as as soon as we walked up
and it was funny because i called in
advance you know because
that's like my one of my nightmares this
idea of like
being turned away or being in front of
people and then being like get out of
here loser
like so yeah so i called in advance
and it was literally like some guy named
mikey and i explained he was like he's
like yeah you can come
and i was like are you sure what what do
i say if someone
he goes say i said you could come so
literally i walk up before i even get in
there
the bouncer at the door was like this is
senior hours
and i was like mikey said i could come i
have asked my and i need issues
she was like okay okay go ahead you have
a guy
you have a trader joe's guy now mikey
you got to say his name what have our
lives become you seem like a club i know
this
guy now you have a trader joe's guy it
helps you get
corn flakes because it's easy on your
stomach exactly
i wish we had more time to talk we have
a couple more guests but this was
honestly very enjoyable to talk to you
it was so wonderful just to see another
human being
gorgeous the podcast is called couples
therapy i
highly recommend it i was just listening
to it just
in preparation for this and then really
thoroughly enjoyed the show oh i'm so
glad
i'm so glad and then there's grants
online so naomi had paragon
thanks guys